on sait que la problématique des frais
accessoires et une problématique qui est
un irritant pour la population dans
notre système public le 14 septembre
le ministre de la santé et des services
sociaux du québec étaient catégorie il
sera interdit pour le médecin de vous
demander un paiement de quelle que
nature que ce soit pour être clair et
donner des exemples concrets la personne
de 70 ans aujourd'hui qui va voir
l'ophtalmologue il n'y aura pas de
gouttes ni et 200 dollars ni à un dollar
né à 5 en dessous
depuis la mise en vigueur d'un règlement
le 26 janvier dernier les frais
accessoires sont abolis ou québec
pour contourner cette nouvelle réalité
les ophtalmologistes de l'institut de
l'oeil des laurentides fond de la
facturation créative
il passe des gouttes aux examens
d'évaluation concernant les tests en
près de six ans une visite à la clinique
nous dévoile que la chirurgie de la
cataracte pour les deux yeux une
procédure couvertes par l'assurance
maladie y est avec une facture de 600 $
pour des examens
on n'a pas d'accord non plus deux comme
annoncé la couleur
donc qu'est-ce qu'un bon sens populaire
pour dans la soumission que nous avons
obtenu pour une chirurgie de la
cataracte avec la pose d'une lentille
mono focale la procédure la plus
courante synthes différents apparaissent
un seul de ces tests auraient vraiment à
voir avec la cataracte
le ct maculaire facturé à 75 dollars
ce test n'est pas souvent faire au
patient par les ophtalmologistes au
québec parce qu'il n'est pas assurée par
la ramq eu les quatre autres tests ne
sont pas médicalement requis et n'ont
d'ailleurs jamais été offerts
systématiquement au patient auparavant
pour une chirurgie de la cataracte le
président de l'association des médecins
ophtalmologistes du québec le docteur
comme fortin a refusé de nous accorder
une entrevue devant la caméra il veut en
discuter formellement en assemblée
générale annuelle à la fin du mois de
mars avant de se prononcer publiquement
il nous confirme que la majorité de ces
tests ne sont pas vraiment utiles ou
essentielles sur le plan médical et que
cette pratique entachent la profession
le ministre de la santé guette en
barrette a peut-être sous-estimé la
créativité des médecins à trouver des
revenus additionnels au lendemain de
l'interdiction des frais accessoires
ce document de l'institut de l'oeil des
laurentides que nous avons tenues montre
que le prix de nombreux tests non
assurés ont augmentés pour compenser la
perte des frais accessoires pour sa part
l'institut nous affirment qu'ils
facturent 600 $ aux patients parce que
le gouvernement ne lui donne pas les 436
$ par chirurgie pour les frais de
fonctionnement que les hôpitaux eux
reçoivent un aveu à l'effet que cette
l'inique privé n'est peut-être pas
viable sans un financement public du
permanent
[Musique]
où
il ya du nouveau dans notre dossier sur
des fraudes alléguées à la société
immobilière du québec mais avant de vous
en faire part
voici un extrait du reportage qu'on vous
a présenté le 3 novembre dernier
des documents de la police suisse nous
apprennent qu'une semaine après le
renouvellement des bons dans ces
immeubles
christian gay d'edf corps fait un
paiement de plus de deux millions de
dollars à un consultant en immobilier de
montréal
est-ce que c'était la première fois que
vous donniez une commission de 2
millions un consultant probablement la
carte et des normes pour un énorme chez
discutable
le consultant transfèrent l'argent qui
passerait de compte en banque un compte
en banque par la belgique jusqu'à la
suisse pour aboutir aux bahamas le
titulaire de ce conte est un notable de
québec comme et non qu'on a vu sortir
était monsieur bartlett qui est un
organisateur libéral william butler
aurait reçu près d'un million mais ils
auraient partagé une partie de cette
somme au moyen de trois traite bancaire
la première pour marc andré fortier qui
aurait reçu 170 mille dollars soit
l'équivalent de son salaire annuel de p
dg de la sic
les deux autres traites bancaires sont
pour les collecteurs de fonds du parti
libéral charles rondeau et franco fava
qui aurait reçu chacun cent mille
dollars
certaines personnes qui sont impliquées
au niveau des transactions immobilières
sont des gens qu'on connaît des jours
qu'on a déjà entendu parler qui ont été
dans l'actualité récente
à ce moment là on voit ces acteurs qui
sortent de l'ong sort de nos boîtes et
puis évidemment on fait une ligne
avec leur affiliation politique